hey everyone it's Mike from Horta flows
and I'm gonna shoot this quick video
showing you one of the ways that you can
use the primary opponent controls with
order flows trader 2.0 and you know this
is this is something this is a this is a
way of using it for those that you know
or want to take some little extra risk
you know those people that like to trade
with tight stops there's people you know
buy tight stops I meaning you know a two
or three ticks there's there some that
are willing to you know risk 15 to 20
ticks but you know the more you willin
to risk at the same time you know your
potential profit is is gonna be a lot
more but anyway I was gonna show you
this this way of using total flow
straighter Hornick order flow straighter
point a prominent opponent controls
feature now brief disclaimer this
presentation is very educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making a type
of investment decision futures train
contain substantial risk cannot for
every investor and investor could
potentially lose all are more than the
initial investment risk capitals money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results now you
know the reason why I go through that
every every time is because you don't
want people to realize that there is
risk involved in in trading so what is
this big secret method now you know for
people that understand you know this is
met this video is meant for people that
use my software you know if you're not
using my software don't say well you
know you don't teach anything well that
I'm teaching it if you have my software
you can you can use it now okay I got
their own template loaded but you know
the my simple template here oft long
templates you just pull it up here so
this is a Nasdaq 15 range chart and what
you're gonna do is okay I don't know if
I really want to see all those
[Music]
imbalances I'll just clear up the
imbalance remove the imbalance
imbalances for now so I'm not that way
it was just be a little bit cleaner
because when you're looking at the
primary port controls it's going to be
you know you're looking for a green or
magenta so here you go this was late in
the day now again this is something you
gotta be quick you know people gonna say
well can you automate this can you
automate this well yeah you can you can
but you know if you're a scalper
you know just watch for these things
primary point of control you know right
539 538 you know yeah it's a move from
seventy to eighty two all the way up to
you know close at ninety whatever that
was 92 but look at this primary point of
control up here now this was interesting
because what do you got up here first
bar you don't have the primary point of
control but yes I know some trap traders
but this part you got divergence a ratio
more importantly your prominent point of
control on a long term bar and what we
do is sell off 72 the owners will call
this I don't know 72 94 or do we sell
off to boom boom boom we sell off almost
immediately down to 88 before selling
off some more down here where you got
this next primary point of control at 77
so you know that out I was a nice big
monster move let me just go go through
some of the other moves for the day okay
well this is bevel 5:30 and 3:30 is mark
it was sort of in fast conditions you
know here you got a nice little move to
250 in the afternoon you know from the
42 ish area you know they just got waxed
got spanked you can see it here is all
zeros you know before it rally back up
there's no my primary point of control
there you know there's this one here
again it I just got swept up before sort
of trickling back down you know that
that one would have stopped you out like
I said yeah you're gonna have to risk a
little bit more on a 15 range chart but
like I said you know if you're getting
you know if you're risking the 15 range
chart so if you're risking
you know six I say six what is that I
can't think right now
dealing with an idiot earlier 72-61 you
know one bar 72-61 257 and a half so
that's not four and a half points you
know but if you can you know if your
winners are gonna give you twenty thirty
points then you know you should be happy
to risk that and get some small moves
here you know one handle one handle you
know here's another nice one here you
know from seventy to seventy a holy up
to you know the eighty-five ish area
another nice move here from an opponent
control right here we would go from the
46 area all the way up to the 60s you
know 66 area that's 20 points 20 20 20
handles alright sorry about that knock
at the door there someone was coming
here to treat the mosquitoes in our
backyard now you know what else here you
know you gotten a little one here now
this was interesting because you know he
sold off from this area alright he's got
another little move here then you got a
primary point of control rally up where
you come back down you come back right
down to this level of the problem at
point of control here so you know if
you're aggressive and got in here you
know again you risk in this one bar yeah
you're talking to move from you know the
72 22 area all the way up into the 40s
you know here you just sort of you know
bounce from here to there so you sort of
scratch the first trade you know the
second trade you probably you know
scratch or maybe make a few ticks on you
know this one this one doesn't work here
just stressed make the move within it
rallies right back up against you
and I think that was basically it for
the day you know it's not something I
like to look at the free cash markets
you know 830's the cash open in the
equities but again you know don't think
that all these just show me there's one
day that it only works there you know it
doesn't work any other day well let's
just go back the previous day here and
go back to the beginning of yesterday
you take it back to the 8:30 time so
here you have one here it's kind of hard
to see that one didn't failed it's just
right after the cash open then you're
selling off selling off anything Bueller
Bueller you got one here
you know we rally back up just poke
through it before you sell off you know
you got one here and notice how we
sell-off
rally right back up through that
prominent point of control before you
sell off again so you know let's say you
say you took this trade you got stopped
out right well you got another trade
here right even if you get short here
you're not stopped out over here and if
you know if you're one of these people
that like to trade the pullbacks you be
getting in again here you got a second
chance entry here let's say you're
getting short right here you know 70 to
62 now your rally all the way down into
the 20s for goodness sakes so think
about that you know you're talking to
move from here all right let me draw the
line there here
now again you know people say oh you
know you're just picking that level no
you know this is the software you know
this is what it does prominent point of
control right here where we rally back
up to rally right up to that price but
even if you're just getting in here you
know in the next bar somewhere in the
next bar 70 to 60 to 70 to 61 you know
what's the market to look at it sells
off cells off sells off you know and
what's the time on this move this
happens very fast
this bar is 839 in 30 seconds this next
bar is 838
in 48 seconds so you got time to react
you know I said even if you're late you
getting in here late at 70 to 60 you
know it's worth getting short at 70 to
60 and look at this you see any green
bars at all you got a green bar here you
know this is five five minutes later and
you're trading you know 30 points lower
30 handles lower no prominence there get
here this one fails well you know it
failed I took the trade and it failed
well did you take the previous trade you
know so I talked about we know one of
the problems that traders have is they
like to start handicapping their trades
you know like well I just took one has
failed so I'm not gonna take the next
one well it's the next one could be that
thirty point one you know if you're
trading when the trade is set up there
too for you to take it you take it all
right I mean you take this one yeah it
stopped you out okay get over it look
for the next trade okay well this one
stopped you out this one stopped you out
but look at this one you know if you got
in on this trade right here so you just
had one lost two lost three loss then
you get this one you know it may be
getting in long somewhere in here at 72
20 um you know you rally all the way up
here where you get a primary point of
control or you're stopped out but you
know you got back you know maybe five
points then you get stopped out again
you know no problem point of control up
there but I look at here okay you got a
prominent point of control here rallies
rallies it sells off it goes up a little
bit comes right back down to that area
to that praana point of control again if
you're aggressive you and me getting
into the next bar if you want to finesse
it a little bit have you even tighter
stop you know play for a pullback around
that point of control but again you're
not gonna just place your stop if you're
trying to finesse it you know you're not
gonna place your stop won't dick below
you know on the market like Nasdaq
that's extremely volatile especially on
a 15 range cart you know you probably
don't have it you know three or four you
know maybe one whole point below there
so if you got long hair or 7225 that's a
fantastic trade fantastic opportunity it
7225 look at that at rallies shoots all
the way
you know look at the 7250 area that's 25
handles you know you're risking you know
what two handles
you know that's ten to one unfortunately
you know there's no product water
controls up here if telling you to get
short catch that move back down
you know you wish there were but you
know and it's like 9:00 in the morning
at this point you know we've only been
open for 45 minutes and you're talking
you know 50 handles there in the Nasdaq
you know this one no this one doesn't
work out you know it's unfortunate it
just doesn't work out it was stopped you
out okay it's not the end of the world
you know I mean are you willing to get
stopped out on you know a few ticks a
few ticks a few points when you can
catch 20 30 points in the in the Nasdaq
of course you would
you've been willing to vision say yes
Mike please give it to me here's another
one okay if you're aggressive in here
you're getting longer on the 27 area you
know it's a 10-point move you know if
you're looking for the pullback it
doesn't come right down to that level at
23 unfortunately only comes down to 23
and 3/4 so about a point higher but you
know what can you do that's that's life
I mean even if you you know even if you
got long in here somewhere 27 you know
and you're still holding it down here
sort of break even you know comes back
down you know it does give it another
push up I don't like to play those big
second look for a second a third pushes
higher I mean they do happen but you
know after a second push up I uh I'm out
I'm not looking for a third push up you
know market may be nice to you two times
but you know a third times not always
the charm and then again here it's like
10 o'clock here we've been opening in
the future in the cash rather for an
hour and a half it's 10:06 problem
opponent control up here 72 28 and a
half you know say you get in here
somewhere around twenty four twenty five
twenty four we'll call it you know you
say you got a late at 23 okay what
happens market sells the horse itself
offers sells off Oh way down 203 that's
20 points so I'm not saying you'd get 20
points you know maybe you take 10 you'd
be happy with 10 points 15 points or
whatever I don't know
you know it's giving you these these
great opportunities you know then this
is this is xn one of the tools that we
have
in the order philostrate her no it's a
powerful one and when he got here you
know prom upon to control this one fails
it just comes up it comes back down you
know if using a tight stop you're
stopped out here for you know six ticks
or whatever but you know again if you
had a wider if you were aggressively and
getting in somewhere in here on the
sixteen area you know sixteen Rio
sixteen is right around here okay well
you get stopped out when you trade down
here
okay that's not the end of the world
look the next trade you know like I said
don't handy start handicapping a trading
system and look for the next trade okay
you know dust yourself off another train
opportunity here you get aggressive to
getting back here around the fourteen
area what happens market rallies where
rallies up to what you you know entirely
saw lift into the 30s up in here you
don't have a prominent point of control
up here and catch this move back down
again you're talking about a fifteen
twenty to almost the twenty point move
there you know so I mean how many points
is that you know I've lost count I mean
I'll I'm not counting up everything but
I'm just I'm just going here to show you
because you know I want you to see you
know how it can be used you know then
unfortunately no problem important
control down there there's one here that
fails
are you gonna piranha point control
cells off to this prominent point of
control so this one's body you know you
probably make a little bit but then this
one you'll lose it then we sell off
again you know then when you get ready
to take off right here yeah and you know
you're talking around the oh eight level
you know it just makes it move all the
way up to about fifteen then just it's
trading sideways then you get here look
at this primary point of control right
here at fifteen you know if you're
getting short somewhere on eleven you
know ten eleven twelve you know it comes
back gets within one thick of that point
of control at fifteen but again you know
on a fifteen range chart on the Nasdaq
you know putting your you know uh an
offer at a prominent point of control
for a cell or a bid for a buy you might
have to sprinkle it in you know rather
than right at the exact level you know
you might want to put it one or two
ticks before and you know scale in one
or two ticks behind as well I'm not a
big fan for scaling in scale and I would
but you know that that's just something
to think about you know depending on how
you trade in your trading plan so you
know imagine you're getting short in
here somewhere around eleven seventy two
eleven
once the market do it sells off or so
soft.i sells off quickly again - you
know that's a quick ten points it comes
down here below seventy two hundred you
get a prominent point of control again
if you're trying to pull back you know
it pulls back in here before
springboards back up nothing up there
turns up ramen opponent controls get
down in here you know pull back it'll
stop you out either way it would have
stopped you out then another prime
opponent control right here which is
right after the cash closed this is uh
about seven minutes after you know you
can shorten again short getting long
because the support of prominent point
of control you know on the 7200 seven I
can't say 7203 but you know the o2
two-and-a-half area being aggressive not
playing a pullback you know - where's
the rallies all the way up to the close
again you know it's one of those things
you know after cash close you get some
nice moves sometimes and sometimes it
just goes stale on you
goes pear-shaped but um you know this
one
you should start running out of time you
know 70 to 1 we call it 7200 2 all the
way up to you know 10 10 ish area before
the futures closed so again you know
that that's just one that's a tool
that's there in the order flows trader
software now if you want to get fancy
you know and add it to you know your
trade plan with some other tool that you
have great you know I just showed it to
you what it looks like using it alone so
hopefully you know you find some value
in it you know honestly there's people
have been writing me telling me this is
transformed their trading I'm not saying
it's going to transform everybody's
trading because you know some people are
just stupid when it comes to trading you
know they don't want to spend the time
to understand you know what the tools
that they're using and how to use them
but you know for the people that do take
that time and do want to learn and you
know do want to use the tools then you
know it's a fantastic tool so thanks
everyone and have a great day bye-bye